words of the world are the life of the
world that line was first spoken by
Wallace Stevens in his poem an ordinary
evening in New Haven not far from here
70 years ago November 4 1949 by Nicky
library has the typescript sheets the
original typescript that mr. Stevens
read from on that ordinary evening in
New Haven and there accompanied by a
manuscript note a handwritten note the
papers are at by Nicky and Yale because
of mrs. Irwin good now Evelyn good now
whose husband was the president of the
Academy headquartered three blocks down
Prospect Street and the note says
Stevens gave the sheets to mrs. good now
who had sat beside the poet and quote
studied his stage fright during the
earlier parts of the program archives
give us extraordinary access to the
humanity of the people represented there
and I have to say this morning I'm glad
to know that a future of puled surprise
winner had anxiety even amidst a
friendly audience seventy years ago I
first read that poem myself when I was a
rising junior in Yale College during a
summer course on modern American poetry
and to riff off of Goethe and the late
great Yalie
Gerry Pelican what we have inherited
from our parents
we must possess again in order to make
it our own that in many ways is the work
of the University and that poem I have
possessed again and again and again and
again and have made it my own if you
happen to follow me on instagram you no
ordinary evening or afternoon or morning
in new heaven as my go to verse even
this morning now today is my thirteen
thousand and seventy sixth day at Yale
I've had a few ordinary evenings
morning's afternoons and even late
nights here I've walked the halls of
this place for 36 years of its more than
300 18 years of existence I've been in
New Haven ER for 11% of the days since
John Davenport first preached under a
huge oak tree not far from here and I
acknowledge moreover that we gather on
land that the Quinnipiac people occupied
cultivated and stewarded for thousands
of years in fact every day at home I
look out over the Quinnipiac Meadows
toward Grannis Island which was a
seasonal home for the Quinnipiac people
and as I look out in the evening or in
the morning I'm reminded as the great
scholar John mentis said that the
Quinnipiac people were people who lived
lives where Thanksgiving was a daily
ritual a cosmology that has much to
offer us even today so I know a little
bit about this place and about its
history and maybe that's why Franz and
Julie invited me to come here this
morning and to share with you but first
some housekeeping before we proceed with
me I invite you to close your laptop's
stow away your mobile phones stash or
Playstations remove your VR goggles and
disregard all digital type devices for
the duration of this talk as a little
incentive you all should have jotters
that you can make notes on and if you're
watching this on tape no you don't get a
jotter there is a benefit for showing up
so I ask that we get out of the cloud
and rest comfortably here on the common
ground of Kroon Hall on this campus in
New Haven that we listen together for
clarity amidst the indistinct chatter
that is so much our digitally mediated
lives that we seek as it were signal
amidst the noise I'm joining you in this
adventure of Yale digital
pluged I will inflict no PowerPoint
slides on you I'm not going to read from
a tiny screen between me and you and I
might even make eye contact as a sign of
respect that you were due in this shared
reality that we make together for you
are part of this program not a mere
consumer of data as my friend case on
great Ghanaian Canadian musicians
tweeted a few months ago the real
conspiracy is to turn everyone into a
spectator today let's all be
participants with our minds open and
active now Franz and Julie actually
invited me as Franz noted because we
shared a great adventure together over
the last year and a half or so to renew
and refresh the binary library website
which i think is the biggest single
all-in project that Yale sites has done
today and I trust not for long will that
record be held but we're glad to have
been the first the project had really
broad participation across the binary
library working with our colleagues in
the university printers office and I
shout them out design of a fantastic
jotter and all that we do john gamble
rebecca Mart's and their colleagues
helped us at the Meineke library to keep
it real and keeping it real was a big
aim of the effort my Niki's director EC
Schroeder charged us from the beginning
and encouraged us throughout to stay
true to our library's 20:27 visions and
aspirations which include and I quote
the call to quote provide all who enter
virtually a level of service
accessibility and inspiration on par
with that enjoyed on-site that our
digital be inspired by and on par with
our actual we had as you may know in
2015 opened a new site at 344 Winchester
stadia they are at home for by Niki's
Technical Services Group and then in
2016
iconic bun shaft building was reopened
after complete renovation and so in some
ways our work culminating on February
21st of this year was following on with
the digital renovation just as we had
had physical renovations before the work
the site aims to evoke the actual and to
provide clear paths for the varied
constituencies and they really are quite
varied
we have 180,000 public visitors on-site
and obviously hundreds of thousands
online we have high-tech folk we have
low-tech folk we have people who are
doing research across all the fields of
human endeavor we have faculty we have
students we have people who see us here
and people who only engage us online so
it's a very varied audience to keep it
real the new look of the website matches
in the digital realm the library's
design systems for print than itself
informed by the physical architecture of
the library that opened in 1963 on the
site in the footer we use Matthew
Carter's marvelous typeface as is used
throughout the university an anchor that
ties us to Yale University overall and
to the Yale University Library system of
which we are apart and then we use as
you've hopefully seen how many people
have seen the new website those who
didn't raise their hands are invited to
but only after we're done and you have
gone off airplane mode and reopen your
laptops we use a universe condensed
family for titles and headers and that's
a typeface that Rebecca uses throughout
our print
it's a typeface the dates to the era
mid-century modern era of the binding
Hughes construction so it also again
evokes who we are and matches with our
physical manifestations in print and in
swag and then we use a bright cool warm
red that is inspired by warm printers
red
and again a color highlight color that
we use across our print and that you'll
see around the building and in other
things that represent us as we go on the
road the results of keeping it real are
we hope as it says in the library itself
quote an inspiration to all who enter
it's a sight that seeks like the library
to be both grounded and boundless or to
invoke Stevens we keep coming back and
coming back to the real to the hotel
instead of the hymns that fall upon it
out of the wind we seek the poem of pure
reality untouched by trope or deviation
straight to the word straight to the
transfixing object to the object at the
exact point at which it is itself
transfixing by being purely what it is a
view of New Haven say through the
certain eye the eye made clear of
uncertainty with the sight of simple
seeing without reflection we seek
nothing beyond reality within it
everything the spirits all come a Cana
included the spirit that goes round
about and through included not merely
the visible the solid but the moveable
the moment we seek nothing beyond
reality within it everything on behalf
of the binary library I want to publicly
acknowledge a name
the people of Yale i TS whose collective
labor made the new website real lisa saw
one dana lib NICUs fronts himself Javon
Johnson Tabor Lightfoot Chow hang Lou
Vincent Massaro Sylvia Perez Julie Ramon
Tia mark Saba and Heather white and also
Rebecca Mart's and the University
printers office and a win acknowledged
the people of the by Nikki library who
kept it real and made this real in the
interest of time I'm not going to name
them because it is everyone
of the by Nikki library who contributed
ideas and time and talent to this site
there are a hundred and ten or so I
encourage you to read their names on the
website after we're done by working with
the Yale sites team we consciously chose
to bring this work home it was a wise
choice outside vendors and consultants
can be great but there is a quantitative
and qualitative benefit in working with
people who are both colleagues and
neighbors is a longtime citizens of Yale
I have been delighted to see how the
homegrown capacity to create websites
here has flourished it's great now as a
consumer and patron that the people I
rely on for digital infrastructure and
design are nearby and that frankly
they're people I run into at the Farmers
Market in Worcester Square and other
places around town happily gone are the
days of back and forth email to set up a
conference call a week out to schedule
an on-site meeting a month out and
instead we have excellent assistants
right next door from real people we
really know and bringing the work back
home also made a difference in the
results you see because all the people I
named know the reality and were informed
really informed by the reality of the
library all of our meetings happened
on-site in the library and there's
something in the air of the place the
people who made this site walk the walk
and breathe the air time after time
after time and I have to say to shout
out Dana and along with my colleagues I
was delighted not only by the time we
spent in a room together but that she
often with her laptop after meetings had
concluded stuck around the courtyard
level and did her own work there
remotely as it were but that's actually
not remotely
and I don't think that there's a precise
quantitative measure that we could apply
to what that Ministry of presence meant
but I am confident the results speak for
themselves of being they're actually
truly being there for you see there is a
virtue with engaging reality that
surpasses the delights of virtual
reality now the work we did together
resulted in a wonderful website that
does work well some here and part of me
Ark wants and the quants will be happy
to know that we have solid data so far
to prove that it works in the first
hundred days which would be February 21
to May 31st the number of unique views
of the homepage grew 5% and that's good
and we obsess a bit about the home page
because in our design thinking we really
prioritized and privileged those who
don't know us and so we really sweated
that in particular so increased traffic
is good you don't want to go in the
other direction that's for sure but
here's the better news average time on
the home page is down by 33 percent
while the bounce rate is down by 32%
long story short not only are more
people coming more people are more
quickly finding ways to go and going
there rather than if we again use the
real building just going through the
revolving door for a while and popping
back out with ever never making it into
the library so these quantitative
measures are really great news and the
trend in the first hundred plus days has
been very good we also have qualitative
testimony in person and online my
favorite comes from our colleague Britta
belly and OPAC who had the powerful
simple reaction on Twitter the fire
emoji it's good if your design merits
the fire emoji
and I'm even thinking that I may use
that as the sum total in the year-end
results column of my managing at Yale
performance process review so the
reality is this more people are finding
their way more quickly and more often to
what really matters the collections the
programs the exhibitions the people the
research the scholarship of the library
and in communications that's what really
matters that's what really counts we
need to measure success not only in the
metrics that Google gives us and that
social media analytics provide but the
measure sometimes quite intangible but
real is how well we serve to welcome
students and faculty and researchers and
public visitors to the place so that
they can engage confront and build on
the rich record of human experience and
cultural achievement that we steward so
a clearer faster website means we can
better serve people as they engage the
past in the present for the future
perhaps our mantra is less time on
website for more time on real site a
clearer faster website is a means
towards the end of more people lingering
wandering exploring and looking for
themselves in the actual library some of
you may know I'm a Kentuckian and
Kentuckians are always happy when other
Kentuckians are cited so I was delighted
to hear words of Hunter s Thompson
yesterday you'll recall them faster
faster until the thrill of speed
overcomes the fear of death now if you
know brother hunter and his life he did
know a little bit about speed both the
motorcycle variety and the amphetamine
variety and his life and living and it's
ending brings to mind another great
saying not of Kentucky but of the world
speed kills
so this kentuckians mantra might rather
be faster faster until you get where you
can slow down and think and engage with
reality for you see we seek nothing
beyond reality within it everything and
so for the binary library a faster
better website means more people might
come to see the real first printing of
the US Declaration of Independence which
will be on view again soon June 28th to
July 11th it is the first document of
the nation printed on July 4th 1776 one
of twenty six copies surviving of about
200 printed in Philadelphia on that day
July 4th 1776 and immediately sent out
on horseback and stagecoach throughout
the states of the new nation it is the
original viral media of the nation and
to see that document is to find nothing
beyond reality and within it everything
when it was on view last year I happened
upon a family who was visiting from
Toledo Ohio who had come to see the
Declaration of Independence on view the
parents were standing on either side of
the case reading it aloud the full
declaration to each other and to their
two kids one declared as she read these
words don't seem so old they seem very
relevant right now indeed they are
once timeless and timely and that is a
reality that is most accessible in the
presence of the real thing the papers in
the Beinecke e library and special
collections elsewhere on campus and
around the world are not dead trees they
are living testimony they are actual
evidence of who we were who we are and
who we might be and so a faster better
website
more people might come to see the first
printing of Frederick Douglass's oration
given on July 5th 1852 to the Rochester
ladies anti-slavery society that is
where mr. Douglass asks what to the
American slave is your 4th of July the
mr. Douglass provided the answer from
the harsh reality he knew mr. Douglass
wrote said and is printed I answer a day
that reveals to him more than all the
other days in the year the gross
injustice and cruelty to which he is the
constant victim to him your celebration
is a sham your boasted liberty and
unholy license your national greatness
swelling vanity your sounds of rejoicing
are empty and heartless your
denunciations of tyrants brass fronted
impudence your shouts of liberty and
equality hollow mockery your prayers and
hymns your sermons and thanksgiving with
all your religious parade and solemnity
are to him mere bombast fraud and
deception and piety and hypocrisy a thin
veil to cover up crimes which would
disgrace a nation of savages words that
echo today this is the 400th anniversary
of when a ship set sail with enslaved
Africans headed to Jamestown these are
words that are timely and timeless for
you see friends there is a virtue in
confronting reality perhaps even more so
when that reality itself is far from
virtuous the reality accessible in
repositories like the Meineke library
and peers across campus around the
nation and across the world have the
virtue of encouraging us to remember and
they remind us that our nation's deeds
do not always match its words and so a
faster better website means that more
people might encounter the first
printing of the women's rights
convention at Seneca Falls July 19th
20th 1848 they report printed at the
North Star Press Frederick Douglass's
press and a report that includes a
declaration of sentiments which I think
needs to be much better known as a
document of the nation 171 years ago the
convention declared we hold these truths
to be self-evident that all men and
women are created equal in 1848 for
words of the world are the life of the
world and a faster better website means
more people might engage more deeply
with the Living Legacy a legacy of
Langston Hughes whose literary archives
live in 672 boxes at the heart of our
campus they might remember his words
words that inspired Lorraine Hansberry
and Martin Luther King jr. words that
echo today what happens to a dream
deferred and a faster better website
means more people might be inspired by
how Hughes reckoned with his reality how
he confronted the past and examined it
and still concluded with an eye to the
future as he said oh yes I say it plain
America never was America to me and yet
I swear this oath America will be and so
a faster better website makes it
possible to enable countless real-time
encounters in the exhibition hall in the
reading room in the classrooms as well
as proxy encounters on the digital
library that oft impalpable impact is in
many ways what counts the most there's a
brilliant Elizabeth Alexander wrote in
2016 when the National Museum of
african-american history and culture
opened and I quote historians and
curators are heroes the dragging the
digging the trench work and sleuthing
the conjuration it takes to piece
together filament by filament a history
and then to present it so that we
understand and experience it as a living
process is nothing short of wizardry
history Elizabeth wrote is not a
triumphal march to the finish line
history is not all upturned faces nor
ascendant history is made up of struggle
contradiction resistance professor
Alexander keeps it real and so must we
keeping it real also means not being
distracted by the brightest shiniest
objects and not diluted by the
disruption machine Yale alumna Jill
Lepore got right what the gospel of
innovation gets wrong in her 2014 New
Yorker piece and I quote disruptive
innovation doesn't explain change it's
not a law of nature it's an artifact of
history an idea forged in time
it's the manufacture of a moment of
upsetting and edgy uncertainty
transfixed by change it's blind to
continuity it makes a very poor profit
professor Lepore keeps it real so must
we
spoiler alert the machines will not save
us by themselves and the evidence is all
around us to see the Valerie Strauss
headlined in the Washington Post a
couple weeks ago new report on virtual
education as it turns out it is too good
to be true as Bret Stevens opined in The
Times on May 3rd over the past several
years we've learned a lot about the
unintended consequences of social media
platforms intended to bring us closer
together make us anger and more isolated
platforms aimed at democratizing speech
empowered demagogues platforms
celebrating community violate our
privacy in ways we scarcely realize and
serve as conduits for deceptions hiding
in plain sight max boot couple weeks ago
in the post ass are we becoming too
stupid to govern ourselves and observed
it's true that the Internet has put a
lot of information online but like
diners passing up a healthy salad for an
artery-clogging cheeseburger
many information consumers are instead
digesting junk news and just the other
day Mr O'Connor reported avenues on a
new study she was writing Mr was writing
in The Washington Post on June 5th the
headline was ditched the GPS it's
ruining your brain when people use tools
the story says such as GPS they tend to
engage less with navigation
therefore brain area responsible for
navigation is less used and consequently
their brain areas involved in navigation
tend to shrink a little bit scary so at
a time when machines are gaining
autonomy are we doing enough to protect
and promote human Liberty in a time of
deep fakes and information overload are
we doing enough to keep it real we
surely can use quantum science but we
also must have quality humanities if we
were to have quality of life as humans
libraries museums and universities stand
is essential Arsenal's for liberty and
democracy they house the living
materials necessary to confront what
Gore Vidal's called the United States of
amnesia where we learn nothing because
we remember nothing libraries museums
and university invite us to be alive in
the world to call forth active citizens
rather than passive spectators libraries
museums and universities should keep it
real in an epicenter when the echoes of
creative destruction runs amok in the
markets we should be in the words of
president salad a a place of creative
construction a place of both innovation
and tradition a place where we draw from
the past in the present to build the
future
president Sall they said Yale embraces
quote creative construction not Orthodox
adherence to the past nor the pursuit of
innovation merely for its own sake but a
dynamic tradition we don't just seek to
make new things we make seek to make
things better now as we collectively aim
to make both better things and to make
things better let me offer some tangible
practical ideas applicable perhaps to
workplace culture first and maybe second
and last get out more often like dana
practice a Ministry of presence let's
not all be stuck in our cubicles or
offices or hotel space wherever we are
routinely where we do the work use zoom
rooms for sure but also make real room
in your schedule to wander to explored
to look closely at this extraordinary
old place to acknowledge what it is its
opportunities its challenges its history
for it is in that that we can construct
the future if you're in its's many are
here communications like me service
providers to departments and schools be
like the yellow sites team was with us
at the Beinecke lee really get to know
the place be in it be present spend real
time on site as we all create things to
live online go to the Grove Street
Cemetery go to the Art Gallery go to the
Center for British art go to the Naval
Museum give yourself the time it will
pay off in many ways and remember words
of the world are the life of the world
in the beginning was the word a book
that's on permanent view at the binary
library says writing matters writing
really matters in this place and for our
world and since it's summer season some
summer reading I have never gone wrong
with Maria pop OVA and brain pickings if
you don't know it read it and read a
book or two or three we should not be
the kind of people who accept Bill bars
blended reality read the actual Muller
report read my dear friend Casey
Gerald's there will be no miracles here
a powerful memoir by recent alum of Yale
who definitely keeps it real and/or read
John Mendez history of the Quinnipiac
people on whose land we stand
acknowledged not only that history but
get to know that history when you visit
the Grove Street Cemetery pay your
respects at the life at the grave of
William Grimes who in 1825 wrote the
first first-person narrative and
published in himself of an escape of a
person who escaped enslavement and lived
in this town and is buried in our
Cemetery at the Meineke library we have
the first printing his ancestors have
ensured that it remains in print a
powerful powerful document and in this
400th anniversary of the arrival of the
first enslaved people on the shores of
what is now our country Reid Ibrahim
Kennedy's extraordinary book stamped
from the beginning to understand the
reality on the ground and the ideas that
shaped this nation and that we live with
today it Brom Kendy does extraordinary
historic and archival work and again
shows that the documents in the history
are not dead it is still amongst us now
so on this ordinary morning in New Haven
I encourage you to stay for the rest of
the conference but get out
more often on this ordinary morning in
New Haven I think we all know we live in
extraordinary times and we need to
acknowledge that we live in times of
existential challenge to what this
nation is to what this world is and as
on this northern air morning in New
Haven we acknowledge that we live in
extraordinary times I encourage you
equip yourselves well the world requires
the reality-based community now more
than ever I shall neither insult your
intelligence nor assault your conscience
you know what to do seek nothing beyond
reality within it everything thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]